hello friends and welcome to the lobby
game spots weekly hangout every tuesday
at 2pm pacific right here on
videogames.com i'm your host daniel
dwyer and
boyoboyvideogames.com are back today
we're going to talk about halo 5. we're
going to talk about assassin's creed
syndicate which is not a syndicate game
very disappointed fragger i'm back uh
we're going to talk about uh guitar hero
live as well
gentlemen yeah we're also going to talk
about dark souls 3 video games they're a
thing video games big fan we're back
like where were they they were gone they
were always here it's just that they
they were inside us all you're like the
justin timberlake of games just bringing
them back i am yeah i'm bringing i'm not
bringing sexy back very relevant
reference from like what was that eight
years ago kids love jt he's like michael
jackson to our generation sometimes
people do when i go to check out at a
store and they're like oh your name's
justin they go justin timberlake like
what really yeah that's that's like no
they don't think it's all just a weird
name it's not like it's really not it's
not like butterworth you know we covered
this yeah
no one ever goes bieber yeah i mean if
your surname was bieber like or if your
surname was like if your first name was
like shaquille i can see people going
like oh like shaquille o'neal but justin
is such like a like don't get me wrong
it's pretty common name it's very common
name that's like saying daniel like
like daniel day lewis is that why you
went with danny because it's just a
little bit more yeah
no it's just i went with danny because
everyone has to have a slightly
different name on the radio
so yeah dino de los does actually make a
reference work because he's irish
perhaps but enough about movies what is
this an entertainment website we're
going to talk about
videogames.com.com what happens if you
go to videogames.com
does it really yeah
how did i never know that guys that's
crazy that's seo sean mckinnis was one
day walking down the street in san
francisco one guy went yeah
videogames.com and he was like what the
[ __ ]
okay
i'm so pleased to know this yeah i'm
just gonna tell all my work for video
games we also own uh kanye's spot
yes oh yeah i actually heard about that
well this is a more recent thing
also works it goes to a very specific
part okay i'm just using that for all
every url i tweet anyway
sorry
actually no we are talking about music
yes
we're here to talk about qatar hero live
yes scott butterworth you have reviewed
this game for gamespot.com yes uh the
review is up now what did you give it
give it a six out of ten six out of ten
which was a bit lower than what a lot of
other people gave the game i was
actually a little surprised to see that
so many of the other scores were
consistently higher than mine i'm
currently the lowest review on
metacritic which
i i'm like i said a little bit surprised
and also lower than you gave rock band
by a point yes i gave rock man for a
seven out of ten yes so let's talk about
what's in guitar your life because
there's lots of different messaging
there's two games coming out they've all
got different systems and like i have to
say like probably one of the most
difficult parts for you reviewing this
game must have been trying to just
communicate what it this game is because
it's not just what's on the disk it's uh
it was a complicated review in part
because yes the game itself is
complicated there's a lot going on in
the game it tries to do a lot of
different things and a lot of new things
but i also had very conflicting feelings
about the game very extreme uh you know
polar opposite feelings of a lot of the
different aspects so trying to reconcile
all those feelings and synthesize them
into a cohesive review proved very
difficult so what what are the sections
is like a campaign and then there's the
easiest way to pull it down right
there's like campaign and then like a
music service thing correct yeah it's
that's basically what the game is like
the the package guitar hero live the
game comes with guitar hero live which
is a campaign 42 songs over live footage
custom created shot with the first
person camera to make it look like
you're on stage so that's all this stuff
that's what you're looking at on screen
right now and then there's also guitar
hero tv which is sort of a music
streaming service thing it's difficult
to describe because it's not entirely
like any other service out there which
does make it interesting but it also has
some really frustrating aspects uh to
its setup let's get that into that in a
second for the moment though let's talk
about uh the previous the first person
campaigny stuff sure so what is that
like is that are those uh songs set in
motion are they like the same songs
everyone's gonna play throughout the
campaign are you playing in different
places in the first person like how does
it work so the way that guitar hero live
is structured is basically you have a
bunch of sets uh that are structured
that under an umbrella of you're playing
two different music fests and there are
different bands playing different sets
of different times each set is a preset
list of songs there are 42 on disc songs
that's what this campaign is using so
over the course of that entire campaign
you play each song as a sort of fake
band within you know set up again as
fests and sets and things within that
and um
you get you know each band has a sort of
different look about them and and sticks
within this sort of genre of music but
all of it is really goofy and
inauthentic and just kind of bizarre um
justin sally you're gonna chime in well
unlike the previous games you're not
creating your own band like this is all
set up but for me like i feel like it's
really cool whenever i watch that
footage of getting that first person
shot of the crowd and looking out and
like playing bigger and bigger venues
and that feels like it would add a lot
of excitement like being there like i'm
actually playing this concert and
looking yeah look at that like for
instance this look at this for a
setup yeah like i'm actually at the
concert he's going to help me get up the
stairs if i were playing this in virtual
reality i this would blow my mind
does it or can you even like could you
even notice because are you just looking
at your notes on the screen so that's
the thing uh when you're actually
playing a song no you you kind of don't
which i think is a big part of why uh
the motions and the acting and
everything are so exaggerated they kind
of assume you're only going to be
watching it from out of the corner of
your eyes they're trying to sell it so
yeah so everything is so hammy and
played up and over the top like every
thumbs up is just like really
ridiculously exaggerated was there
someone with a sign at one stage that
said you're you're they're a bunch of
like weird generic designers they're
like you're cool or like good job band
like it's it's just it's very good job
back
you know i don't think
that's but it's very zero in one like if
you're doing a good job you see good
stuff you're doing a bad job you see bad
stuff it's not like it transitions it's
a very
quick wait wait is this tony hawk five
what's going on yeah see that's the
thing so so first what justin was saying
is true yes there's good it's either
you're doing well or you're doing poorly
that's it there's no in between and it's
the the two are very extreme i mean
you're either like i said you're either
an irredeemable embarrassment or an
absolute guitar guy i mean this guy's
got a skateboard he's an embarrassment
but yeah and then so the other portion
of it that really
i found kind of grating is that it's
just so inauthentic it just does not
feel believable and anyway nothing about
it yeah it's like it's the most
enthusiastic roadie that has ever
existed like a parody but there's
nothing about it that is sort of
self-aware or silly or playful
look at this one is this i haven't even
seen this
i guess uh andy bauman uh must have shot
this it's a boy with uh fellow producer
josh yeah josh shaw he's pretty running
the show at the moment in the back and
then there's rob his biggest fan
you are cool
this is great oh i i would pay for this
as dlc are we oh really can we do this
we're in talks right now to bring this
to the game
and so and when you're playing these set
when you're playing the single player
campaign you you have some songs that
are unlocked where you can do a quick
play but you actually it's a very it's a
throwback to older guitar hero games in
older rock band games where you have to
play every song in order to unlock them
in quick play and play them with another
person yeah there's a lot of sort of
annoying throwback stuff like that yeah
so if you want to just jump in and play
with your friends you really kind of
can't like the campaign is single player
only so all the videos if you're
watching it was built for you know a
guitarist right from first person so
there is local multiplayer stuff as well
you can do yes so you can jump into
quick play within live but all of the
songs except for the first track from
each set is locked so you have to
actually play the single player by
yourself to unlock the tracks in order
to play them in quick play okay which is
like didn't we decide 10 years ago that
that was a bad idea and that you should
just be able to access content right out
of the gate i mean that
why you weren't paid for the game like
why gate the content like that it's just
silly and that's just one of a handful
of examples of that kind of strange you
know step back let me for example if you
ever pause the game it'll it'll count
you back in but it's the same counter
regardless of the tempo of the song or
where you are in the song so inevitably
when it starts you back up you're gonna
miss several notes it's like i mean rock
band handles that a lot better i mean
again there's just a lot of examples
like that where it's just
it could have used some polishing these
are such easy things to fix and stuff
that was resolved years ago that it just
kind of back pedals on it's weird let's
also talk then about the actual songs
because that's you know one of the most
important parts of of a game like this
uh in your review i read that uh
i guess most of the songs from this are
taken from like top 40 from the past
five years pretty much
it's primarily focused on top 40 pop
music not a lot of like you know
previous games would and rock band i
think especially does a good job of this
it'll pick songs that even if you don't
know them they are appropriate for the
gameplay yeah there is you know an
interesting guitar hook or you know the
guitar is sort of the focus there's
something about the song musically that
makes it interesting and fun to play
yeah with a lot of these songs they're
popular and you'll probably recognize
them because yes they're all like top 40
major label songs from the past five or
so years yeah with only a small handful
of exceptions
but a lot of them are not built for this
kind of gameplay they'll have like one
single line or you know guitar hook
that'll just repeat for the entire verse
and this you'll play the chorus then
i'll go right back to the verse and
ultimately the song will have just like
three different parts over its entire
duration it's just not fun to play and
then you also get stuff like skrillex or
eminem yeah
yeah again like really popular artists
but those songs like the skrillex song
literally doesn't have guitar in it no
wait it screams for like 10 seconds of a
guitar lick and then the rest of the
song no guitar but you are playing so
you're playing like the cynthia sounds
and dubstep noises it's but it's just
why you're making a game called guitar
hero why would you not pick music that's
guitar driven there's so much good
guitar driven music why would you pick
these songs it's just it doesn't make
sense so that's on the sort of guitar
hero live campaign stuff yes so explain
what the other part of this is because
this looks interesting in terms of at
least the library of music that's
available yeah so that's the sort of
natural segue between the two the guitar
hero tv offers way more music but the
way that it provides music is
not really like anything we've seen
before in a music game so you know
traditionally you could buy a song as
dlc and you would own the song you
played whenever blah blah blah
qatari tv does not do that in fact you
cannot buy songs you cannot there's no
way to permanently unlock a song so you
can just play it whenever you like so
how do you get access to new songs so if
you want to play a particular song if
there's something that you find in the
game's song catalog you're like oh
that's a good one i want to play that
song you have to spend a play
to play it just that time okay it's like
a one time you spend a play you play the
song and you can't even restart the song
if you screw up
where do you get these plays so you
accumulate plays uh
basically every thing that you play in
guitar hero tv even the stuff that
you're paying to play
or spending plays to pay to play that's
confusing go for it uh
everything you play you get coins and
coins you can spend on plays or you can
spend like custom note tracks and stuff
like that do you get those in the
campaign as well or is that oh no it's
okay specific to guitar hero tdot and
you can
also real world currency like you
inspect actual cash to buy plays yes but
you don't have to you can you know
accumulate coins by playing the game and
spend that how often do you accumulate
coins to get players see that's the
thing um
not
so a single play when you when you play
a song you are not earning enough coins
to buy another play so inevitably you're
going to run out of players and the game
is pretty generous up front by giving
you chunks of plays like you beat the
tutorial and it automatically gives you
oh here's 10 plays spend them on
whatever we want to get you into our
marketplace yeah do you know how many
songs is it like three songs it's a
little over 200 songs no in terms of how
many times you have to play to get one
of these yeah so
two to three songs depending on your
performance will net you enough coin to
purchase a play but then you can also
buy them with your own money okay so
what's the rate on that
uh so you can on a 10 pack of plays cost
you about or not about it costs you two
dollars and fifty cents okay for ten
for ten plays but again the game is
relatively generous up front it'll just
give you chunks of plays and you are
earning currency no matter what you play
and the primary way to earn currency if
you're not just spending plays on the
songs you want to play is the guitar
hero channels
so basically the way the channels work
is there are two of them they offer
different programming generally one's
going to be more pop focused ones going
to be like rock and metal focused and
it's just a constant stream of preset
music videos kind of like old school mtv
like you could tune in to mtv or dvd2
and it would just be they're just
playing music videos or last fm radio or
spotify radio or any one of those
services that sort of like plays a bunch
of music although unlike something like
say pandora you can't put in suggestions
it's just whatever the game is playing
that's what you're going to play well
unlike spotify as well spotify you can
pick songs you get to choose like here's
the thing that i want to play and this
is more like groove shark where it's
like and i'm going to play these
in
so there's channel setup like you are
going to play songs that are kind of
within a genre so like but there's only
two channels so the delineation is like
really they're in very big buckets
there's not much separation that's all
free
yes the channels are absolutely free
yeah that's like fun because that's like
a type of discovery as well it forces
people to yeah
this was um where i broke from most
other reviewers a lot of people seem to
really enjoy the channels and i really
don't really um and the main reason why
is i just want to have more control over
what i'm playing if you spend 60 dollars
no sorry a hundred spent a hundred
dollars yeah because you have to get the
new guitar you can't play this game
without the new guitar that comes with
it which makes sense and we'll get to
that in a minute because the gameplay is
awesome but to finish up with the guitar
hero tv um the channels that you can't
you can't even skip a song i mean
seriously it's like television where
whatever's on is what you're playing um
so if something comes on you're like i
hate this artist or i hate this song
this isn't fun you're just either stuck
playing it or you quit and you go play
something else assuming you have the
plays to go pick a song you actually
enjoy and to me that just feels weird
and i feel like it kind of
very it just funnels you into the micro
transaction system so you can
technically play without paying
like presumably a couple of more
channels might have fixed this problem
and they are planning on adding a third
channel but they haven't even indicated
what their channel will be like they
haven't talked about this rock will be
split in half so it's it's the whole
system just feels weird to me because
it's like if you have to worry about
having enough currency to play the
content you want it fundamentally
changes how you're even thinking about
the experience like uh is it worth
spending a play to play that song or who
am i gonna really have enough and you
know do i need to grind through songs to
earn coins and i don't want to think
about that that type of thing again it
certainly feels like it's going to be
down to like the consumer like are they
comfortable with it to me
sounds like something i might not be
into but aside from that let's talk
about the sort of the physical aspect of
this yeah the new guitar does it play
well does it feel like you're learning
how to play guitar hero again like i say
in my review the mechanics are really
what redeem the entire game for me
i i feel like it really does
successfully reinvent just the core
mechanics that drive the entire genre
and that's a serious accomplishment i
mean that took some real thinking and
some deft execution to even make that so
by that you mean
so the way that it works now is
traditionally you had five buttons all
in a row just linear right and you know
what sort of made it tricky was you had
to extend your pinky down or move your
entire hand to get to that last note
right so the way that this new guitar
works is it's actually six buttons and
they're laid out sort of side by side so
you have three buttons on the sort of
the upper part of the neck closer to
your body and then three buttons
directly underneath that closer to the
floor so you're switching uh not only up
and down on the fretboard but back and
forth
between one side and the other
and so that allows for a lot of really
interesting new patterns and variations
in the note charts and it does force you
to completely relearn the way that you
play these games which is exciting
because it makes it feel fresh and new
again and just the process of learning
and developing your skills is super
rewarding it's always been rewarding
it's what made the genre such a hit in
the first place or a big part of it
anyways excellent so to recapture that
and make it new it's like that's that's
huge guitar you're live six out of ten
on gasebo.com yes um i guess wait and
see if that's the sort of type of model
you want to buy uh is there dlc coming
out first they do they've stated that
they plan to continue to add songs
guitar hero tv right their plans are
slightly vague but uh from what i've
heard they want at least 70 new songs in
by the end of the year so they're going
to funnel people into that aspect though
yes all right uh justin scott thank you
so much for coming on and talking this
is all about guitar hero live of course
we'll be back in just a second we got a
bumper show coming up uh dark souls 3
assassin's creed syndicate halo 5 and
more uh but first of all let's check out
this new trailer gta 5 stuff is still
coming out so we're going to go check
out some low riders
we out here gang-banging like it's 91.
you feel me
i'm a hustler
gangsta
king of the castle og
the ballers and the vogels care way too
much about floss made low riders but a
fool and this low rider are soon
partying
smoke them fools and get gone you feel
me
oh [ __ ] it's tobaccos they riding on
you take more than three lunatic gangs
and no ideas to stop lamar davis
hey what's up friends
eric hey america here mary you're on the
couch oh my god this is great what's
going on back there
josh is on his own no dan's with him
nothing's on fire don't worry about it
damahur's putting out fires we can have
you here for like five ten minutes uh
because dark souls three uh to you got
to play it this week or have been
playing it um uh since monday and i know
you're kind of in the same boat as me
because you're a blood you've played
bloodborne but you're not a big souls
fan correct that's the same for me but
mary you're a fan of the series and
you've been playing them all just the
dark souls one i didn't play demon souls
but yeah so i guess the question is uh
what is your initial impression of dark
souls 3 what's new first of all mary
yeah there's a lot of new stuff that
they're adding to try to revamp it first
of all you're way faster they've
increased your stamina and stamina
regens faster so i think they're taking
a little bit from bloodborne and they're
trying to get you to move around and
dodge a little bit more although it is
still very uh
focused on using a shield and then
attacking although that's not tay's way
tay likes to dodge
but you'll find in a lot of these fights
i can easily run away um and i can kind
of dodge i can run past enemies really
quickly which you were able to do in
previous games but i think they're
encouraging it more they want you to be
moving around a little bit more so the
stress test was on was it just monday
last week yeah it was friday to sunday
at specific time periods we had about
three hours each day yep um to try it
out there were four new classes well i
mean like there were four classes that
were playable i think there was only two
before
this stress test so the two
new ones is the academy assassin and the
herald of white and the herald of white
and they both have magic
the herald of white is kind of more of
like one call him like a cleric paladin
but he has uh the ability to buff
himself his attack and his defense
uh as one of his spells and then the
other one uh allows him to heal and then
he also has lightning strike and then
the academy assassin is very magic based
um they have three magic moves there's
um there's a dagger which is really
quick there's a
longer move this kind of does a little
bit more damage and there's just this
giant circular sword move
which is really rad uh so another new
thing is there's a mana bar and they're
letting you
uh regen your mana at um
at bonfires and then they also have an
ash estus flask which is similar to your
regular estus flask it just regens your
mana
and because of that estes flask you can
just
burn through your mana you can just go
go go and pretty much do magic tricks
all day which i thought
they always tried to not let you do a
lot of ranged attacks and dark souls
they want you to be up close they like
that close combat
but with but with the magic man you can
just rain down hogwarts on these
[ __ ] run train on pretty much
everyone from a long distance i found it
a little op but uh the problem with
judging this is that it's a stress test
this isn't a demo this isn't a preview
build a lot of this stuff isn't final
yet i even asked them yeah well it's
alright until march so presumably that's
right there's still some some stuff that
they're they're working on here um
i asked them about the um
the cap on your
your health as in previous games when
you die you lose your max health and it
goes down and down and down until you uh
until you get your humanity back yeah
and in this one um in this demo that
doesn't happen and i asked them about
that and they said they hadn't decided
yet oh wow okay so there's no way to
know how your health is actually and
that's a huge change right so there's so
does it feel like there are big changes
because then the other problem i always
feel with these games is that whenever
and like i'm not a massive fan so i
can't speak to it personally but
listening to conversations in the office
it always feels like the real changes in
these games like aren't really apparent
until like a week or two weeks
afterwards and people are like diving
into it and like figuring out how each
game plays differently so when just did
it feel like a different sort of dark
souls experience like when you compare
it to something with tattoo specifically
i would say that it's in the same realm
they've made minor tweaks there's a
little bit more speed there's um arts
now there's weapon arts where you can
change your stance those are great
tweaks
but it is very much in the same vein of
the first two i found it i mean the
locations like the dilapidated areas
even the bosses um
they kind of just have a similar feel to
them and i don't
i wouldn't say that this is a huge
negative i think for a beloved fan you
might find it this is what i wanted i
want more of what i love and that seems
to be what you're going to get how about
difficulty because these games have
obviously prided themselves on being for
the you know being punishing but fair
presumably now we've had so many of
these games that people have kind of
figured out how to play them so does it
is it feel harder than previous games in
that respect or does it feel like the
same or it feels easier oh easier really
i mean like i think for me going into it
first again because i haven't played
dark souls so like you and me the same
playing bloodborne
um just kind of getting used to the pace
it is a faster so i'm definitely gonna
play this when it comes out but uh i was
getting punished in the beginning
because i was just so used to you know
either having my gun and being able to
stagger or like i was
using the dodge a lot even though you
have a shield you know and you can block
um and that's a very dark souls thing to
do right but i was playing it like
bloodborne you know she's like i'm gonna
dodge everything and i think
like after like the first time you go
through bloodborne it's kind of a
struggle getting through each part of it
but then you get you learn and you get
better yeah and then your second
playthrough you start going okay how do
i how do i refine all those things i did
and then like you're trying to pull off
all these visceral attacks all these
backstabs and all that all those things
i think that's going to come with time
especially with this game so i think
it's still hard
like how hard you know i didn't play
dark souls 2 so it's hard to say but i
think they're they're still like a
slight learning curve um because you're
you're still learning like enemy types
attack moves right that's really what
these games are about it's like learning
how they're gonna attack you like what
are their attack patterns like but then
that's probably a lot of this is
probably new for you so did you feel
like that mary or did you kind of did
you think you had all the enemies
figured out largely because they're
similar to the previous game he's right
there is a learning curve you know that
boss takes a lot of time to take down um
i felt in general though because i am
familiar with a lot of the way you would
see a generic skeleton guy that i knew
how to take him down um but again
there's a lot of fine-tuning so there's
a lot more to it than what we see and
then this is invading someone else's
world right that's another live player
well that's a whole nother can of worms
like that guy is hard and i
this is
this was a tough one for me
how was that lag uh it's real
is there a third person there is in fact
i don't know if i look up there's about
four other people up there watching and
cheering us on
so we're all fighting each other uh does
this happen just randomly during the
your playthrough uh well you decide to
do this you use a red eye orb and uh
those are like an item that you can use
as many times as you want in like a
specific area uh well yeah in this area
at least for this demo it took me here
you gotta find the if you're red then
you want to kill the white guy and if
you're white you want to kill the red
guy right so it's kind of like a
multiplayer mode as opposed to the sort
of
uh you know killer
constant persistent multiplayer thing
that we've known in the dark souls that
like offhanded leaving notes and whatnot
definitely this is just like you just
drink something and you're in a
multiplayer match it changes it up right
um and it's it's aggressive this that's
me yeah i did not
come on three on one it did not survive
but yeah the messages are still there so
like most of them uh at least from the
test when we played were pretty legit
there were some trolls like i read one
word like illusionary wall ahead and
it's literally right in front of you and
i was a dumbass and i try to walk
forward and then like i was like wait
that didn't work and i tried hitting it
it didn't work you know but there's
still co-op too so that's pretty funny
you're supposed to vote those down or
out facebook i totally voted that one
down once i me i appraised it with a
negative right
i've been doing the same in assassin's
creed syndicate yeah
two stars
oh yeah we're talking about talking
about that
that's coming up
stay tuned
um but yeah i think uh in terms of
another thing that you want to see from
a dark souls game from dark souls one
that had these really wonderful
intricate um
levels that when you went into an area
you came out maybe back at the beginning
where you started and they they would
have these wonderful ways of weaving the
world in and out so you always felt like
you were you were in this labyrinth that
never ended it was really beautifully
done i i was
i was a big fan of that dark souls 2 not
so much you kind of went to the end and
then you turned around you came back
in this demo even though it was very
small this stress test
everything
warped back
and there were parts where it wouldn't
let me go forward but if i looked off
out in the distance i could see where it
was going and it was coming back around
so it looks like the level is more
it's more intricate and it's more about
weaving it back to where you began which
is really exciting for me because i'm
excited to see how they do that there's
nothing better than getting to the end
of an area and taking an elevator and
finding out that you just saved yourself
20 minutes yeah exactly yeah most
satisfying thing in that game just came
back in bloodborne as well and it's a
good feeling to know that even if like
how do you know that you've progressed
in a game like that you know you always
feel like you don't progress
but when you get to a bonfire you get or
you use your souls and level up or you
get one of those elevators you unlock a
door like i've done something i
accomplished a lot and i've saved myself
a lot of time so it's good to
good to see that those are making a
return excellent so are you guys uh
optimistic then about bloodborne going
it's so quick oh sorry not bubbling
straight it's it's crazy to think like
it's another game to look forward to
that's but it's not there for like
another six months it's good though
that's good yeah it is you know you can
we got we got time to play all our
winner titles you know you got the
fallouts the tomb raiders of the world
bloodborne expansion on its way uh you
know halo obviously an assassin's creed
so we have all that time to play that
stuff and then right around the corner
next year you know we'll have a dark
souls game but i'm excited it looks good
um again i haven't played a dark souls
game but bloodborne totally got me
hooked got me into it nice and after
playing the stress test i'm i'm i'm
ready to play this one so excellent
forward to it all right we better let
you guys get back to actually running
the show before at all
before the fire consumes us all uh eric
taymor kish thanks so much for coming on
and talking to us about dark souls 3. uh
we're going to be back in a second uh to
talk about assassin's creed syndicate
myself and ty played a bunch of it on
monday morning alexa ray korea is doing
the review we're going to let her finish
that and we're going to have a
conversation here with josh saw so we're
going to swap out backroom staff
for just a moment we'll be back though
in the meantime check out this trailer
for wwe 2k16
it won't be a nice day
make me sick
um
hey what's up folks it's late october
you know what that means assassin's
creed season yeah joshua is here ty
roots here i'm here hi danny we've all
played assassin's creed syndicate this
week uh we did a bunch on a live stream
tie you taught me cricket i did i taught
you how to play cricket thank you it's
very important you shoot the person who
gets bowled out yeah or caught out in
the face right it's fine josh i think
you played a lot more than that actually
i did i ended up playing it like all
weekend really yeah wow what percentage
are you at uh like 28 oh wow you're
weird yeah you're flying yeah i'm on
sequence four maybe five now okay yeah
we're not going to talk about some
specifics later in the game um we can't
talk yeah but let's talk generally so
assassin's creed okay first of all let's
let's all like
you know let's just
put out put it out there our own
assassin's creed histories so
josh are you founder series
yeah i played every assassin's creed but
i did play one and then i thought two
came along two came along and picked
like everything i had no problem with on
one i played like a little bit of three
and then four was cool with black flag
yeah right it wasn't called four right
no black flag and then yeah that was
really messy with the numbers yeah
three i didn't like four was cool and
then this one i'm all i'm kind of into
unity i didn't touch though okay or
rogue thai
uh i might be the only person here that
liked one oh i liked one too you did
okay so i thought it was cool just yeah
yeah i mean obviously rough
it's the same way i look at mass effect
right like the first one you had
problems but i still loved it i still
like um assassin's creed one i like that
time period uh two like josh loved uh
played brotherhood did not play
revelations yeah uh skipped that
played three huge american history buff
yeah so i was i tried to get into it but
um there were some problems there
did not like black flags okay i was kind
of that it just didn't fit for me yeah
and the whole abstrago story and
everything just wasn't there
and then uh unity played about maybe 10
hours out okay and you play more unity
than i have did i okay i loved one two
and i know yeah exactly right it's like
the same story it's like uh i love it
but the french revolution is cool yeah
so yeah i love the one i love too i love
brotherhood revelation same thing yeah i
played maybe
15 hours got sick of it yeah three i
wanted like didn't really get into it
exactly yeah i was a huge like us uh
history buff at the time as well yeah
yeah and like i didn't understand
anything that was going on oh i loved it
i mean i i liked the way they portrayed
washington is is very i think they did
their homework on that like he is con
he's taught in school here in the states
that he's like this renowned leader and
that he was like amazing and awesome and
you know nine times out of ten no one's
going to talk [ __ ] about george
washington but we're not here to talk
about george washington no we're here to
talk about
charles goddamn dickens and florence
knight
yeah so like i'm also not a fan exactly
i'm also not a fan of unity and then i
kind of want this one to be good yeah
and i think so right at the gate i was
not a fan of the early tutorial missions
it just
feels to me like
they just the storytelling in these
games has become so wayward it just was
way too bombastic way too explosive uh
and sort of sure of itself but then once
it opened up into london the first thing
i thought was like the actual
environment of london is pretty
spectacular it's amazing it's really
they did their homework here too i mean
that you can tell that they actually had
a lot to go off here you know like when
they made when they made london they
made the burrows and everything else
they had pictures they had photographs
they were able to recreate everything
pictures yeah yeah first yeah in the
history well the other ones were too old
to have pictures so they could use those
references yeah so now they have like a
good reference point right they can
recreate london the way they want to
obviously it's not one-to-one but you
know at the same time it's like it
doesn't need to be the whole part from
westminster up to trivago square
whitehall and buckingham palace it's
actually like i was just walking around
going oh i bet horse guard parades right
here and it was right there yeah so josh
what did you think of howard i did i
mean it's kind of funny that they've had
so many of these games and they force
you through these tutorials and it's
like yeah why we know how to play the
game just like set us in the open world
and let us explore something is like a
bit of a frustrating start um but at the
end of the day i was like
it's a pretty cool game i had no hope
for this like unity looked pretty rough
and i was like i'll just try it out and
capture the footage but like i was i was
pretty into it and like
i don't know i think that they did it
this was the second time they used the
unity engine right so they could polish
it over the year sure there were
glitches but they weren't like
they were just normal game glitches they
weren't like those horrible yeah it's
yeah switches are going to happen it
kind of looks fresher it looks a little
bit more restrained as well like it's
not i kind of i'm looking forward to
seeing what it looks like on pc when
it's out in november um what did you
think about the uh actual missions so i
guess me and ty have kind of we've gone
around the same length into the game
like not that long like about five
percent through okay yeah i'm probably
around that as well yeah and i played a
bunch more yesterday um so you're a bit
further on did you what did you think of
the missions because i was finding them
quite like basic early on already josh
uh it was weird it was really
frustrating to me because i like to play
it stealth style yeah and there's one
thing i've always hated about assassin's
creed which is when you walk down the
street in your normal clothes yeah and
every guard's like hey you stop and then
this place you go anywhere and it's just
people giving you [ __ ] everywhere and
they they introduced a cool mechanic
where you can like put on your hood and
go into stealth mode and i thought like
they'd see you then
and then like or like that would be
suspicious but if you were just walking
around in your normal top hat yeah why
are they recognizing you like everyone
in london knows who these twins are and
that just ruins it but you're not even
from london yeah you're from like
the fries these secret assassins i'm
still waiting for someone to be like
assassino
just come after you know but like it's
yeah i agree with josh it's a little i
don't understand why this who wins the
stealth for me a little bit but what
about the actual likes solutions
sometimes there are some cool like high
style ones like some of the more like
sequence enders like it'll show you like
cool ways to beat it like you can
pretend to be dead or something and like
kind of beat the mission that way the
stealth stuff though like there were
just some of those quick ones where it's
like sneak into here and it was like i
had to find this clue at a pillar and
it's like okay i could come back at any
time of day but she decides to do it
while the enemies were giving a speech
at the pillar
and it was like all roped off and it's
like why would i need to do this right
now yeah there's no reason to do it i
tried it over and over and over again
trying to stealth my way in and then
eventually like had all my like gang
members like attack the guards and i
threw smoke bombs everywhere
oh and then one by one i whistled and
had the guys come over and i
assassinated him into the haystack and
he's like this is not the most
satisfying way you could do this totally
i think that that's a really good point
that i've
experienced as well is that like i feel
like all the time there's like one way
to complete these missions and you got
to do it that way and coming out of like
the witcher 3 and like metal you're
solid yeah it feels like really straight
i don't feel like i
have the freedom to figure out how to
solve anything it's like oh no you wanna
you wanna kill all these people then you
know
you just better i just felt like i was
doing it right but it wasn't working i
felt like i was stealthing how i was
supposed to but it just they'd still see
me or whatever and it didn't feel good
and also like sometimes weird things
happen and it's like that worked out all
right but in metal gear you know it was
set up to work like that yeah and in
this it's just like oh it looks like the
game didn't stop it from stop this cool
thing from happening and the other thing
ty you were mentioning before which was
that in in we talked about it i think on
monday would it make your solid when you
and it's hard to like
keep
comparing it but like this definitely
does feel like sort of a different like
an old type of open world game as
opposed to what we've seen with the
witcher metal gear but in those games
whenever you got caught by the guards it
felt like oh everything's changed it's
like it's a charge situation and now i
have to like figure out a way of beating
them that way whereas in this you just
mash square to kill them all and then
people who are like 20 feet away didn't
even notice you can kill like 30 guys
and then it's like okay you're clear
yeah yeah that yeah you have it's weird
because i think the formula for most
assassins games is like you get caught
you you piss off a guard or you piss off
a bunch of guards you look for that line
out right it's like that one line and
there's multiple paths you can take but
you you have to go hide right you have
to climb a building you have to parkour
over a wall hop on a pole and this one
it's kind of cool because you can hop on
a carriage hop on a pole
you know well have you guys gotten the
zip lines yet no see that's that i
haven't even gotten that you because
i've changed a lot yeah i didn't think
i'd like it but it's really cool and
actually l1 and basically like like
batman hooks you can actually straight
up like up a building and you can go
like between buildings so it's cool
because if you're trying to take out
guards in an area you can air
assassinate him and then just like zip
right back up and then like scout out
the next one or if he's in between
buildings you can uh like kind of climb
across it and then be right above them
and air assassinate them like you can
make the ledge
yeah the devils are great too so it's i
also love the uh the skill points and
using jacob and evie separately like you
can fine-tune them to your play style so
like if you want if you want to approach
a mission super stealth you know you can
when ev's better for that you know then
you can actually like kind of use your
skill points to like level her up yeah
to a specific playstyle and then you can
use jacob who's like the over-the-top
brood right who's just going to like
[ __ ] [ __ ] up and punch stuff around and
like cause some causal ruckus but you
know there may be a mission that calls
for that so
it does mix it up a little bit i think
it gives you variety so that parts
obviously i think is a bonus from a plot
side too like they do they have kind of
their own agendas and so there will be
like separate missions for them have you
enjoyed the story because i've actually
found the story to be quite like like
not good first i enjoyed an assassin's
creed story because they just jump
around between individual characters so
much and i like i remember beating black
[ __ ] uh black flag and i had no idea that
was the end it just yeah yeah it
happened and you're like wait this is
what i've been uh trying to do this
whole time it just keeps jumping from
all these like weird like capes and like
eyes and all this stuff and i think it
all happened at the end of like
revelations so i missed a lot
but they just don't focus enough on
what's going on with the characters it's
interesting i'm actually quite surprised
that you're you're sort of you're into
it and you played so much of it over the
weekend um it i think one of the points
you made that definitely resonated with
me which is that like i i kind of went
into this with low expectations this
like this feels to me like a game like
infamous second son or like batman
arkham city where they're like oh it's
that old style of like here's a bunch of
stuff to do in a map
do like they're gonna there's gonna be
certain amount of repetition there's not
that many like side questy stuff it's
kind of just like an old style open
world game and have fun with it yeah as
opposed to like what we've seen with
other open world games this year where
it's been like dynamic storytelling and
like you know having crazy different um
uh like ways of attacking bases and
emerging
million units i think gameplay both
right unity was the first assassins that
was specifically for the xbox one and
ps4 then they made rogue out for the
previous gen so now is will this match
that sale total because it feels like so
it definitely feels like a game that
like an annual franchise at this stage
where it's like it's not really a
formula yeah it's a formula yeah and
we'll know now like we'll see how many
units it pushes when it releases next
week i just what you're saying about
open world though is like i don't play
this like an open world where i like
walk around and see what's going on in
the park yeah i was like i'll go tackle
i'll go rescue these kids from this
factory i'll go like take out this base
and like each of those little things i
had some fun like stealthing around it
yeah as far as open world though it's
it's like the it's so not believable it
doesn't have that gta completely
unbelievable you're [ __ ] ramming down
like these these horses can take
lampposts to the face like i've never
seen there's a little collectible it
says like wanton destruction or
something yeah have you seen that so i
once i realized like oh i can get that
by doing lampposts i just ride down the
sidewalk now just knock them down boom
boom boom boom boom and it's a horse
running through like hundred and trees
too and
like people are just like gormless
idiots like there's dead bodies in the
street and they're like oh whatever
what was that thing over the bridge
yesterday oh yeah i was trying to throw
dead bodies over the bridge oh yeah
there was just three people walking
towards me in the middle of the bridge
like enemies and i threw a knife at one
of them in his face he died and the
other two people were just like chatting
to each other there's like a dead dude
on the ground then i kill the two of
them and this guy in a truck like a
horse goes up and he just stops in front
of him like i can't get past here he's
like move yeah so i picked up the bodies
and try and throw them over the bridge
and he's like waiting for me to pick up
the last body it's like
yeah in like gta people would be
screaming yeah and running everywhere
and it's like there's that attention to
detail that you lack sometimes it has
the like environmental attention to
detail it does but you're right it does
not feel like in like a mod it's not an
open world where you're wandering around
thinking like oh i wonder what i'll see
around this corner yeah it's like it'll
be another dozen idiot londoners yeah
yeah i mean i'm still it'll be a guard
yelling hey yeah
if you don't walk away then i'm going to
chase you i'm going to knock your block
something like that
i mean i still want to
it's really weird it's like they think
you're an assassin they think you're
[ __ ] with them and it's only when you
sprint away that they're like oh it's
fine okay cool yeah if you just act
normal they're like still giving you
[ __ ] in the middle of the street
if if they were so recognizable they'd
wear disguises like i don't understand
why they're just walking around where
every enemy knows their faces and their
clothes
that was the one thing that um
that i guess i guess it bothers me in a
lot of assassins games but just the npcs
they all just look the same like yeah
the guys that are after you dude
i don't know how many like bald burly
guys that yeah that is there one girl
model with yes short hair and she's on
your team or the enemy team they just
change the color of her clothes yeah so
the bald brute guy yeah and so that's
another thing they have all the
different types of enemies right they
have like um the big fruit guy they have
the sniper they have the scout and if if
you fight any of them you mash square
and then dodge and press x if they have
the gray bar and match square yeah just
press x when it literally says x above
their hands like it doesn't matter who
it is you just press those same buttons
and they'll die yeah
combat's not not great here but i like
it's like but it's brawler if you go in
with like expectations of what this game
is it is an open world
like
interesting setting it's not really
pushing the
you know i don't want to live in the
needle the challenges are fun like the
missions have like kind of bonus
challenges and i don't get all of them
but i aim for those and that kind of
gives me like yeah
and i don't even want to knock it too
much in the combat i mean the thing is
it's a it's oh i hate the combat but
it's representative of the time of that
era like no one's no one has swords
anymore like no one does that stuff so
it's like you have to adapt right but
it's like brass knuckles now and you can
punch in the witcher but you still have
to like block like i guess that's true
this is just like evie with her stick
just
it's kind of cool though she has some
cool animations though there was uh some
cool stuff that was doing with tv uh
like two days ago where like she has
like these awesome executions that i
thought were like finishing those when
you have like two when i'm since you're
like three just in the eye and i got
really like
i just remember like altair and like the
first game where it's like you work so
hard to kill
one person and by the time you're done
with the tutorial with both those
characters i'd murdered like 50 [ __ ]
they expected you to run in the first
one like these people yeah but like now
now these people are just sociopaths and
honestly you've killed thousands of
people it's kind of like games in
general
like i remember like in the first games
it was like oh this is like an invading
army where it's like nowadays just like
street thugs so these are just londoners
who've got families and you're just like
you're like really yeah and then you and
why are you doing it for your gang which
is doing the same thing also i like i
killed the guy and then i like moved the
camera and they're just two kids
looking at it and i'm like you know i'm
supposed to be a good guy but i just
like walk away it's okay timmy the kids
are the most crime-ridden thing in this
entire game yeah anyway that's our i
guess impressions of assassin's creed
syndicate but it was all right yeah i
don't i don't want to bash it it's not
too but it's not a bad game at all i i
don't think i think it's just you know
it's assassin's creed it's just and if
you like this is a pretty good one too i
think yeah i think if you know what an
assassin's creed game is at this stage
you kind of know what syndicate is yeah
uh but our official review will be up on
the side uh i believe wednesday midnight
is when it's getting posted there's no
it's thursday at 4 a.m thursday 4 a.m
okay specific pretty soon so make sure
you go back to gamespot.com if you want
to see alex ray korea's uh review of
that for gamespot.com all right thank
you so much gentlemen we got one more
section so many games yeah so many games
got to get robbed out here uh to talk
about some halo 5. but before we do that
overlord fellowship of evil overlord do
you remember overlord i haven't i've
never heard do you remember overlord
games is it one of these games
is it one of these is it with the
minions it's like xbox 360. apparently
there's no one of those let's check out
the trailer
the forces of evil have had a few
setbacks recently
tinkerly goodness is on the rise
spreading cuteness and hugs across our
once corrupt and unpleasant land
so we've called in a few reinforcements
those who understand that evil isn't
just what you do it's who you are
the nether ghouls
kryos inferno
melody
and hawker
each uniquely skilled for spreading
mayhem
and grabbing loot
and summoning minions
no they do like their hats
and there she beats bliss this scabby
black hearts
where was i hi yes these dark heroes
will have to work together or alone to
thwart the forces of shininess
but no one's here to make friends at
least not for long
so sharpen your weapons test off your
minions and get with the carnage
because evil always finds a way
then video games just keep on coming and
there's a new halo the fifth halo game
rob handler hi eric tay hello
uh halo wars is that count odst
yeah uh both you gentlemen have played
us uh what have you played so far
because it's not the entire game yet
just the campaign okay have you
completed the campaign i actually have
not i'm a mission shy i've been really
busy this week but eric has
completed it yes but we're not going to
talk about story specifics no that's
fine
yeah okay multiplayer stuff is starting
soon enough we're going to get to play
it yes this week okay tomorrow tune in
and we'll be doing some probably some
live stuff oh excellent that'd be cool
as well as co-op so co-op we'll see some
of that as well tomorrow sweet so we
might get you back on the lobby as well
to talk about that then next week uh so
i guess the campaign you guys have
played it first of all rob how does it
how does it play does it feel like a
halo game
it feels like a halo game more so i i
like this game more so than four okay
four uh to me felt like kind of
desperate in some ways like how it you
know multiplayer wise it like tied in a
lot of like
seems like forced call of duty elements
like ordinance drops i remember being
at the moment kind of turned off by it
but this
um off the bat like just playing this
game
feels so great does it you're a massive
halo fan i've seen videos you playing
like halo 1 and 2 and like really sort
of remembering the good old days does it
feel at all like that it does and that
it's it's much more simplistic like
there aren't
these class-oriented things so far it's
kind of just you know it's got this new
mobility thing it's kind of like the
trend now right it's the ad and the dash
having like
you know uh
mantling and all these different moves
but it just flows so well like
it was so easy to pick up like the the
power abilities as like much as you you
know some people aren't into them you
know you do like a ground pound right
you jump in the air and you charge up
and you slam down enemies it's so
gratifying it's it's a blast and it just
fits in really nicely and what about
like environments and stuff today like
one of the things i love about halo is
just the diversity in the levels um like
big sort of outdoor stuff like fun
internal um spaces and then crazy sci-fi
elements and different planets and stuff
like what what does halo 5 does it have
that sort of diversity in it oh yeah
definitely uh first and foremost it's
beautiful it looks amazing um you know
different planets and different surfaces
and stuff like that i think just
speaking with you know rob and even mike
who play a lot of halo uh they're saying
you know for the first time that there's
just so much more verticality there's so
much more space to kind of roam around
different paths you can take that aren't
as linear right um so yeah you're
touching on that that's so big like um
halo 4 for instance i enjoyed the
campaign but
there wasn't much of a drive to go back
to it yeah this was almost frustrating
in the element of like i was constantly
trying to look around for things to do
because there are so many different
paths you have one of the abilities you
have is called a spartan charge where
you can kind of
you know like plow through an enemy
wherever but there are these paths that
they they basically hide from you like
you can basically find flanking
maneuvers by plowing through a rock
formation and and um coming from behind
and there was just yeah here he's
listening you know i'm constantly
well this is me just exploring like an
idiot
there's intel you're looking for right
so that's right so yeah there's you know
and
touching on that just a little bit more
is is basically you can see this being a
really great co-op experience because
there's so much to
do and see in these games and replay
again like i'm looking so here's an
example of this you'll see i plow
through here do it you idiot do it
in the crack oh yeah so you go and you
can now flank an enemy it's a lot of fun
stuff like what's the rest of the
gunplay like as well because the halo
sort of has this you know
the formula is like well known of like
the ai the way i guess the movements the
the way the guns work the sort of the ai
in that game has never been like the
cleverest thing but it's almost been by
design so like how does this feel does
it feel like a normal halo game where
like you're playing groups of different
types of enemies that fight in different
ways and you're having to like figure
out who the strong one is and then
totally you know what's not like it's
it's great i think it's at its best um
more so yeah
the ai is never outstanding you're not
you know you're not blown away by them
doing any tactical maneuvers but you
you take each enemy and you handle them
a lot differently now for instance there
are these knights right from the older
game they're more jacked up you have a
new enemy that's kind of like the
soldier who are replacing these knights
now the the knights kind of leveled up
and they're extremely difficult right
and you have to handle it really
differently we have to do is basically
shoot its glowing armpits great it's
cool uh but that's where they're located
uh we'll show you but you shoot this and
you get one chance to basically get a
one-shot headshot
and if you don't get it then you then
you have to shoot the other armpit so
there's like
there are these tactics you have for
each enemy like hunters now um i don't
believe before but more often they you
throw a grenade at them and they'll
they'll bounce right back at you all
right so
it's tough it was tough and i figured
that one out
right and there's just tons of different
enemies and you handle you handle each
one differently and i think that's more
predominant than this one than
any of these
good variety as well throughout the
mission
you're not fighting the same three
things all the time not really no no
yeah you know you get hunters this is
kind of always
a part where you get two hunters you
know um but it's a good variety uh for
each for each map
we talked a little bit about the
environmental stuff i think you're not
allowed to talk about the thing i want
to talk to you about but you said you
played one of the best levels you think
in the history yeah i i just to touch on
it lightly without spoiling anything
you can't talk about specifics but it
was just a really uh
breathtaking moments yeah where i was
like i paused it and i had to text me
like this is the best halo level ever
played
just just and this was you know 10
seconds in yeah just because it was it
caught me off guard it was really fun
yeah basically just to
lightly touch all right it's just a
physics thing it's like it's like they
just they change something really cool
let the viewers and you enjoy it oh it
was like whoa that was one of the
coolest levels i've played like it
reminded me of like you know like silent
cartographer from like yeah where it's
like an open world you know handle this
mission however you want so it's just
one of those things like the opposite of
the library yeah on the other scale
because speaking of cartographer
actually let's talk about the vehicle
stuff a little bit sure so what happens
with vehicles you're not a big fan of
the vehicles no i don't really yeah i
just yeah so
i know it's a staple of halo things halo
game sorry and maybe some people are
going to kill me for this but i think
even rob had some slight frustrations
with it too it's just like as you
progress through the game as you know
you are going to get on a warthog you're
going to you know you're going to get
into different vehicles
and just some of the
some of the
ground transportation just frustrated me
a little bit and like here's the point
right here is this mission where you uh
operate a mantis now
what gets frustrating i can i did this
on heroic and this this took me really
long i mean legendaries where it's at
and i will play on legendary for sure
but man on this this on legendary must
be so tough because what happens is you
know you go through this long trek in a
mantis but by the end of it you see i'm
glowing red because if i take one hit no
then i'm done so and it like
through checkpoints it's keeping the
health yeah yeah okay you're like it
gets and this is kind of just get out of
this is a staple like okay start over
but you can't get out of it you can yeah
yeah but they don't give enough they
should give you like more like a lot of
these
vehicle missions you ditch a vehicle and
you get another one yeah that happens a
lot this one not the case you get one
mantis but by the end of it you're like
you're just frustrated because
you're so conservative with like how
you're playing like any small hit you're
done and so you're redoing checkpoints
pretty often
um and it got a little frustrating he
didn't like it he said he want to throw
a controller i don't blame him
this is eric eric cat mariota we're
talking about here yeah but like it was
just more of like because you know
you're in you're in the mantis and you
think okay i should be able to mow all
these guys down yeah because i'm in a
mantis you are literally on the field
and i should be able to yeah you want to
feel that
my my gatling gun or whatever chain gun
and just like just
destroy them and then instead there's so
many of them that it's like oh i guess i
kind of gotta tactically cover my
vehicle that's supposed to be way
stronger than these just you know so a
specific sort of like you have specific
things here and there you guys are you
know think
it doesn't work perfectly but overall
sounds like you're pretty optimistic
about it yeah i'm i at least campaign
yeah campaigns is pretty enjoyable there
um there's one thing i want to touch on
is like there's one thing that like just
kind of nagged me in the wrong way where
you
like other halo games sometimes you know
you um
like master chief collection you you you
look for
um you know like easter eggs like like
uh terminals and this one it's mission
intel each mission has like
i don't know eight to twelve mission
intel they're like pickups little and
you know it's a tape recording and it's
a little bit of the story the story is
sometimes hard to follow in general
um
and you know you find these voice
recording pickups and you play it what's
frustrating is that it will play over
often more often than not has happened
it was playing over the story dialogue
in game style okay yeah so too much
again another sort of you know nitty
gritty
thing but which we'll get to in the
review but when the story is like you
know they're they're throwing you a lot
of plot during the actual gameplay and
so when that starts happening i get
frustrated because i'm like kind of
missing out on stuff of course you can
go back in the main menu and you know
review all your all your but apart from
that sort of like you enjoyed it oh i
very much enjoyed it yeah again the the
gun play
it feels like such a halo game
and that's just huge for me it's simple
like
you don't need to somebody you know like
i feel like advanced warfare all these
games are tacking on all these
you know crazy glitchy movement stuff
but this is like a really tasteful kind
of like black ops 3's doing this like
just a tasteful you get one like you
know i mean you get one boost yeah
either you're you're jettisoning out of
a fight
or you're using it to your advantage you
know you're doing a juke move on someone
so it's a tone it's it's it's a nice
balance it's good to hear uh and then
the multiplayer stuff when you guys
streaming that's too much i don't know
where
i won't guarantee anything yeah uh we
need to look into that but we're
definitely playing tomorrow we're
definitely playing co-op tomorrow i know
just to hearken on that point yeah i
think campaign was fun is is pretty good
um but i think we can all agree that if
we were able to do it co-op i think it's
like a lot better i would have enjoyed
it i think so i guess i guess you'll
find out um so we'll get you back on
next week to talk about co-op and is
multiplayer involved in that as well or
does it just go up
i think
those are kind of lifting at the same
time okay because they're kind of
looking at the same thing so much halo
so much video game in that uh yeah
coming out in just a week's time october
27th is that right yep yeah yeah
actually it's around the corner it's
around the corner video games they're
coming out danny we're almost done here
we've got one more thing left to do
we're giving away a bunch of sick ass
pokemon to rating cards and this is one
prize all this stuff we've got two
copies of it so we're gonna get one two
three four five three of these packs
these trading card game things and then
two i guess they're starter packs right
what to say on the front there
yeah mercury says it ancient origins you
could collect all 1
and 5 900 pokemons uh by getting this
bad boy all you have to do is follow
gamespot on twitter and retweet that
picture of mary and her pokebuddies
420 have already blazed up and hit that
rt button uh so make sure you're in
there as well i'm guessing this is north
america only
most likely
most likely it says eric day great
impression in the market um
yeah so make sure you get on that just
hit rt button hit the rt and uh you got
a chance to win some pokemons pokemon
pokemon i wonder if shoes in here chew
yeah and go
pokemon oh
neil garb no door no gargoyle
uh right here uh all right that's the
show uh
hit that you guys want to get out of
here so you can hit retweet and win all
this stuff oh you are so on point
nice
are you gonna do it i thought you'd get
it you think you can oh stack it yeah i
think you got it dude don't you know
that's like my other hobby is stacking
all right thanks to damahorg for helping
out this week there is garbedor
what is it like rubbish
rubbish is the is the previous evolution
of garbedor
rubbish
he's getting i heard one second it side
by side got it oh that's that's asking
for a lot vanilla is the ice cream ice
cream cone right and like the evolution
is a second scoop wow look a second
scoop
yeah that was rubbish
rubbish is that really what he looks
like yeah i thought he was bigger than
that no he's a [ __ ] well he does
nothing for scale so oh yeah it's true
yeah rubbish and garbador
give us some vanilla
yeah duvanil
he looks like it's like an ice cream
pretty much this it's evolution is it's
got a second scoop
vanilla v-a-n vanilla but like yeah
exactly yeah
just type in world's dumbest pokemon
it'll be the first one to go that in the
keychain
[ __ ] keychain pokemon
what you got it all right it's coming
she said yes
it's almost like a soft serve yeah
almost yeah that's real dumb anyway you
can get all the trading cards who knows
there might be a cleft key and a vanilla
in there and a rubbish or a garb door uh
the only one way to find out hit that rt
button we're done thank you so much
joshua mary kish eric taylor's right
here uh dom hork as well uh for uh
running the wheels of steel back there
when everyone was out here uh we're done
for today but loads of news on
gamespot.com loads of features make sure
you check back in later in the week for
our reviews of assassin's creed
syndicate and more uh but in the
meantime have fun play some video games
and we'll see you guys next tuesday at
2pm pacific adios
you